[Applaudissements]
c'était simple question on actuelle via
vous êtes des grands professionnels vous
devez tout connaître
ah bah oui c'est vrai à la fin le
gagnant sera désigné cadors de la
semaine et tout le monde devrait
l'appeler monsieur ou madame tout le
reste de l'émission
il y aura évidemment à perdre on se sera
le poker de la semaine
la semaine dernière juste y avait marqué
un point dès la première question ne
vous emballez pas quoi qu'il arrive
est ce que vous avez peut réviser
d'actualité swing se moque de moi
les premières questions chefs qui sont
exceptionnellement aujourd'hui ces deux
points là voilà alors vous connaissez
notre passion suspecte pour les
telenovelas cette semaine on a regardé
les épisodes 120 à 123 200 tas de diable
à sur france ô on n'en est pas sorti
indemne
regardez bien ces textes et coups de
poing un pavé dans la mare de la fiction
télé santiago voilà ta mère et ce
médecin au fil de leurs discussions ont
dit que le mieux serait hospitalisé
pourquoi dix mois ce qui t'arrive
[Musique]
deux fois en deux points que va-t-il se
passer ensuite à la à le type en veste
va sortir des noms de chaque roue et
faire des mouvements menaçant mais le
type en baisse à montrer sur son
smartphone une sextape de santiago et sa
belle mère dolorès troisième proposition
santiago va planter une fourchette dans
les pôles du type en veste et dernière
proposition le type en veille c'est à
dire bah alors on n'attend pas patricio
vous tapez sur vos tablettes
répondez vite vous a répondu
alors quelles sont les réponses on
regarde tout de suite b à c à d vous
avez tout le monde a répondu alors on
n'attend pas patricia on regarde la
réponse
[Musique]
à
ah ah
non je te laisserai jamais recommencé à
me gâcher la vie umberto je te laisserai
pas faire
qu'est ce que tu as fait ton tiago je me
suis défendu pouvoir réponse j'obtiens
présente mes excuses à madame turbide et
ce qu'elle allait vraiment bosser parce
que je trouve très belle santiago donc
je suis les hnwi jeu très bien surtout à
se protéger on est courageux le gac à la
fourchette de continuer comme ça le
feuilleton est ce que vous trouvez qu'il
surjoue un petit peu le mec regardez
bien de l'épisode l'expression de son
visage quand il se plonge dans ses
souvenirs
on a essayé de comprendre à quoi il
pouvait penser à ce moment là juste toi
[Musique]
mais j'aime beaucoup c'est un mec cool
et à qui on peut parler de tout en toute
décontraction
c'est bien
au bout du rouleau
les ballons une question on va vérifier
si vous avez du néo aaa
cette semaine elle n'est pas sans savoir
qu'ils constatent ses calculs et tout ça
c'est pas pareil alors cette semaine une
grande salle à lancer son nouveau parfum
à trois points qui a laissé quelle est
cette star il n'y a pas de proposition a
répondu gilles verdez gilles soucy
hapsatou sy
kim kardashian rihanna beyoncé mon
meilleur non c'est pas bouder la mecap
victoria beckham et bien personne à
moubarak acheter smartphones il s'agit
d'une vraie star alain delon michel
sardou
je vais montrer moins 16 j'avais perdu
toute valeur et je suis ni de quoi ces
unions non consenties celui qui a sorti
son partenaire mans c'est benjamin
castaldi n'a exactement on à la
publicité
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
j'explique ça c'est une vidéo que
benjamin c'est l'humoriste y avait pas
de bruitages de proue la vidéo c'est
très difficile de se montrer un petit
but morning qui cachait un peu mes
fesses qui n'est pas le cas là chez moi
jamais décollé j'aimerais et des
benjamins à un moment vers le pauvre il
a peut-être des problèmes et peut-être
alors j'ai congrue telle figure je ne
consulte après la fête c'est les gens je
ne je ne ne pète pas ça m'arrive comme
tout le monde donc mais moi vous faites
mais c'est pas moi l'essentiel de votre
carrière rien un bien beau prout
j'en suis fier voilà donc je vois là je
ne m'en cache pas aller vers de vous
tous mais vendredi que le bruitage des
chocs illégaux les fils qu est la raison
même si je sais pas pourquoi il a posté
ça mais y est magnifique j'ai envie
vraiment avant qu enfin si j'étais
gaulle et je le ferai alors vous
connaissez bien venu chez nous oui nous
le concours de chambres d'hôtes chaque
jour sur tf1
cette semaine ont découvert un endroit
bucolique où les vaches broutent en
toute liberté
regardez nos vaches aubrac qui nous avez
combien de têtes 28 vaches aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment du plein air intégral
donc ils se font plaisir en faisant du
bio de la qualité
[Musique]
animaux tout ça ils ont un devoir de ces
magnifiques en sorte qu'ils sont en
bonne santé heureux tu leur en donner
chacun un petit nom est ce qu elles sont
baptisées oui sinon ça va deux colonels
et jacotte avec leur pays pour quatre
ans
ils essaient de suivre du banc ils sont
fous mais j'ai des éclairages nous
faisait mourir avec leur père matters
est bourré de méthane et benjamin qui
veut nous faire mourir donc être au
point selon vous comment s'appelle la
vache à justine et nabila c'est isabelle
des jean-michel allez vous tapez sur
votre tablette est bien répondu ah ben
si vous avez bossé vous vous avez
regardé avait répondu dix ans les races
de vaches ont fait leur prénom c'est bon
moyen de réponse
c'est assez partagés se joue entre
nabila isabelle fils simplement on
regarde je regardais chacun un petit nom
est ce qu elles sont baptisées wii est
gentil non ça va de deux colonels
jacquotte dans la même demi heure une
coupole
l'intro causé nabila
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention maternelle qui vous met à
l'amande année c'est que bosser les gars
un petit point sur les scores elle est
en tête avec trois points deux points
mais je sais pas d'ailleurs comment
parce que là ça oui vu que c'était une
question 4 points je pense qu on va
refaire les calculs
oui elle est chouette à 3 3 ça l'a été à
4 à bâle passer à la suivante
non si c'est pas la peine demandée c'est
pas la peine alors si un jour vous vous
asseyez sur votre télécommande vous
pourriez tomber sur tf6 et les missions
du couple parfait sympa le concept 20
célibataires venus chercher l'amour et
après se débrouille alors vous allez
voir dans cet extrait un candidat ou une
candidate se livrent à une sorte de
portrait chinois revisité regarder si tu
étais une oeuvre d'art à la picasso
pourquoi donc vient beaucoup prendre
soin de moi où je marque beaucoup et je
trouve pas au picasso a fait d'être
ébauché dame
quelle est la toile prix cas ce que tu
préfères cinq fois sans la toile de
picasso queneau et la jeune fille
préfère à la joconde b la c4 picasso au
seco palma des selles avec des taches
rouges dessus une merde
vous voulez vous confier un petit peu
benêt qui me dit désespéré allez il faut
il faut choisir
allez on regarde vous avez choisi quoi
en majorité la joconde un moyen que je
signe jean michel et delphine qui ont
joué la différence on va voir qui a
raison
quelle est la toile complications que tu
préfères je n'aurais pas tu la décrire
mais il y avait des taches rouges dessus
ça lui sert d'or
[Applaudissements]
on a commencé moi je me suis dit enfin
une nouvelle émission avec des couples
et tout ça pouvait être bien mais sa
part trop trop nous voulons la
téléréalité avec les clash avec des gens
qui ont un niveau un peu basique et
c'est dommage ça ressemble quand même
beaucoup et la télé réalité veut à la
base j'espère y aller c'est mérité de
dans le temps vous savez par exemple moi
je les hais les trucs de l'amour là
c'était sur une chaîne sur un bateau
l'émissaire de la gcc venir a été moins
les gens étaient s'était déjà produit il
y avait de ça les plages alors que
maintenant c'est vraiment un boulot quoi
et c'est toujours l'état sauvage les
implants c'est l'attenté jusqu'à la télé
réalité c'est juste qu'ils avaient envie
à la base
bon après c'est parce que on a
l'impression que c'est un attribut
officie obligatoire c'est surtout des
gens pas longtemps hostile à il a adapté
son michel si un jour il vous dirait
alors prêt l'agefi essayer de mieux
connaître nicolas lui posant deux
questions et vous allez voir elle
s'attendait pas du tout à cette réponse
si tu étais un événement historique
un événement historique je pense là la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale en
ça devait être une belle journée je
savais qu'il était vieux mais de là à
connaître 1945
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a les stéréotypes des garçons machin
bodybuildé 1
et puis les nanas je trouve ça donne pas
une bonne image des jeunes d'aujourd'hui
parce que espérant qu'on n'est pas tous
comme ça c'est pour ça aussi le doigt
est ce que vous êtes comme ça un petit
peu quand même
les pauvres en fait moi je les plains
c'est vrai qu'on les gars sont les
cachent tous et toutes à participer à ce
genre d'émission qui sont d'ailleurs
regardé par la jeunesse aujourd'hui mais
c'est des gens qui sait sa part il faut
dire la vérité je pense que l'interview
en entrevue entre les deux a duré une
demi heure et qui pose c'est évident
décaissé présente et on est bien content
ça nous fait des sujets français faut
pas chercher loin moi pardon ma de
discuter avec mon bon coup de jeune et
quand on inclut mon fils quand ils ont
sorti au roi de france c'est le maximum
et sur la peinture et sur l'histoire
vaut mieux qu'on enchaîne avec la
question suivante parce que là pour
l'instant au niveau des points au niveau
des ponts c'est jean michel et daniel
qui mène la danse
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible je pense que générant
si bien remarquer 1,2 kw à la première
qui a marqué notre village et 1.0
contester les règles s'il vous plaît
arrête de jouer moi qui se sont plantés
vous allez nous manquer des gages aux
questions chaque semaine
idf1 diffuse une telenovela angolo
portugaise mara une femme unique avec
une qualité de dialogue assez étonnante
on dirait du woody allen vous croyez pas
regardez ces scènes où deux personnages
vont évoquer un lourd secret pourquoi tu
revenus mi temps car tu me manquait et
mes enfants aussi que tout enfant cet
enfant que tu as abandonné sur le rayon
des choux au supermarché pour six mois
y a pas de proposition quelles réponses
madame qui passa s'appelle mitton 1 va
donner à monsieur batta pas écrit
qu'elle a abandonné un enfant au rayon
des foules maison c'était sur les
carottes non 6/4 au rayon des roses non
celui que j'ai donné à ta femme femme
mais enfin je n'avais pas le choix que
de faire ça tu le sais très bien il est
super bien
si tu t'en a été occupée connard
j'aurais pas dû l'abandonner
ralentissez look vraiment il avait fait
pas il adore le défi oui mais c'était
pour te faire ta fameuse soupe aux choux
alors écoutez c'est vous dire il n'y a
pas la bonne réponse avec lesquels qui
s'en approche et je vais lui accorder
les points à cesson préparez-vous orgie
parce que s'avère difficile voilà on
regarde car tu me manquait et mes
enfants aussi que toutes deux enfants
sept enfants que tu as abandonné sur le
rayon des choux au supermarché
c'était des laitues bosser alors on le
sait dans un bar tout peut arriver
surtout passé 23 heures alors vous
connaissiez les brèves de comptoir en
voici une à laquelle personne ne pouvait
s'attendre
regardez bien ça va aller très vite
normalement vous avez déjà vu cette
image
il est 10 heures du matin quand un
client inattendue entre dans ce bar pmu
de chantilly
pour 7 points pourquoi les clients de ce
bar pmu se met il à courir paniqué il ya
un sanglier qui rentre à un sanglier qui
rend parce que le client sent très
mauvais castagnet a pété au ça peut pas
tout miser sur bâle benjamin est un
cheval qui rentre un chat un chat à
cheval non c'est un braquage
alors il ya deux chevaux les cadets vous
avez répondu il ya trois chevaux la
police arrive la police arrive
non il ya une bonne réponse autour de la
table on regarde et le cheval il est 10
heures du matin quand un client
inattendue entre dans ce bar pmu de
chantilly
ce cheval au galop sème la panique puis
s'en va après un rapide aller retour
juste le temps de casser quelques
chaises sans faire de blessé la vidéo de
cette scène insolite a été diffusé en
ligne par le propriétaire du café
la pouliche venait d'une écurie à un
kilomètre de là elle a été récupéré peu
après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ce que je veux dire au faire un
point sur les l'âge il allait dire la
semaine rien vous étiez content de
gagner très content profitez-en parce
que c'est mal parti
vous êtes à 0 isabelle aussi benoît
c'est vous qui êtes une des quatre mois
ils sont à 13 devant hockey comme ils
viennent me gonfle et on enlève le point
tirez pas sur une ambulance quand même
très très bonne
un point on les enlève aussi parce que
ça c'est pas possible
allez une question tout peut se jouer là
dessus c'est la dernière question du jeu
à 20 points 9 points sur ce match parce
que cette question tous les jours sur w9
se joue le match dans le monde entier
veut connaître le score
est-ce que je pars de real barça au psg
om mieux les marseillais contre le reste
du monde
c'est un peu la ryder cup de la télé
réalité et à la fin c'est toujours la
langue française qui perd regardez
plutôt
écoutez maintenant on peut ramener la
capote jeu quand je touche cette espèce
de pot ça me dégoûte sévices que m
ça pue la capote il se sent pas bien
qu'ils dehors de la carnoy qu'elle se
remplit pas et ajustés alors pour 9,3
selon vous que son train train de fleurs
les candidats il traîne une vache
vitrine vaches la pâtisserie de la
pâtisserie
ils sont en train de faire des saucisses
avec une machine d'issos israël montré
ma la pâtisserie je pense aussi à la
poche la rdc sur la couture à quoi bon
à quoi bon train de capturer un serpent
il sait qu il avait coûté le texte comme
mobile à mignon c'est la cata d'une
automobile annuel ils montrent une tente
mais il manque une tente à l'écouté il
ya quelqu'un qui a marqué neuf fois
bah ouais jean-michel pas j'ai pas
regardé mais quand on fait des saucisses
comme ça et il faut
à
[Applaudissements]
bon ça arrive et ça remplit la carte
soit et ce sans arrêt qui se tordent la
capote elle se remplit pas et ajuster
bing des sports écoutez c'est une entrée
fracassante pas puisque le cador du
poste cette semaine c'est delphine
wespiser
[Applaudissements]